pronouns main purpose is to replace
nouns so we don't have to repeat the
same words or phrases over and over and
over again it's really a matter of
convenience imagine if you had to say
did you tell Archibald that Archibald's
mother is looking for Archibald and
while there are lots of different kinds
of pronouns there's one type in
particular that people tend to care
about the most the personal pronoun the
short little words we use as a
substitute for a person's name for
example where did Divya go she went to
the store now you may have noticed that
they is both singular and plural in our
chart here that's one of the big fusses
about pronouns these days but I'm here
to tell you that singular they is
nothing new the Oxford English
Dictionary traces it all the way back to
1375 and that's just the first time it
was written down we use singular they
all the time when referring to an
unknown person such as in does anyone
know what they want or each student took
their books home with them or if you're
BBC avoiding MasterChef spoilers however
we know that language does change over
time and today singular they can also
refer to a known person who chooses it
as their self-identified pronoun they
was even chosen to be the American
dialect society's word of the year in
2015. but that's just scratching the
personal pronoun surface I'm Dr Erica
brazovsky my personal pronouns are she
her and this is other words
[Music]
other words
anyone who thinks pronouns can't change
must not be much of a history buff
because they forgot what happened to
second person pronouns in the 17th
century during the early modern period
English had four different second person
pronouns thou the ye and you which
Shakespeare took full advantage of kind
of like with the Spanish 2 and usted the
and thou were informal and familiar
while you showed more respect so in
Romeo and Juliet tibble says Romeo the
love I bear thee can afford no better
term than this thou art a villain while
in Richard II York addresses the king oh
my liege pardon me if you please but in
the 17th century thee and thou fell out
of fashion and were replaced with the
catch-all pronoun you of course there
was a fuss people are wary of change one
guy in particular George Fox the founder
of quakerism wrote a full-on book in
1660 calling everyone who used singular
you a fool and an idiot and who's a fool
now buddy I think it's you
well nowadays you can refer to one or
more people some regions do tend to
distinguish between singular U and a
different plural the most widely used is
y'all which is typically associated with
the Southern United States although also
found in South African Indian English
Maori English and in parts of Canada
other common regionalisms in the US are
use guys uins and yin's outside of the
US in Trinidad you might hear Alia in
Ireland yees and Barbados and that's
just English many other world languages
differentiate not only between singular
and plural you but also between familiar
and respectful versions of you in some
cultures just drop their pronouns a lot
of the time because the information is
built into the verbs in the sentence
when people think of personal pronouns
especially when referring to themselves
they tend to think of gender they is the
most common gender-neutral pronoun but
there are even more which is where Neo
pronouns come in third person pronouns
Beyond he she or they which may be used
regardless of gender expression like Z
which dates back to at least 1864 and
here from the early 20th century both of
which are in fact entries in the Oxford
English Dictionary
people have various reasons for choosing
the pronouns that they do and as members
of society it's our job to respect that
gender aside personal pronouns are an
interesting Bunch take the word we for
example two little letters but a whole
variety of usages like the Royal we or
people saying we're pregnant we can be
used to claim group identity your
favorite team does well yeah we made the
playoffs but if it didn't go so well
they lost if I say we should hang out I
mean you and me if I'm telling you a
story about my weekend and I say we went
scuba diving the Wii doesn't include you
if your waiter says how are we doing
today they really just mean you
sometimes we is used to deflect
responsibility we don't think it's a
good fit but really I'm the hiring
manager who isn't feeling it
pronouns are tiny words but they say a
lot more than you think in the secret
life of pronouns social psychologist
James W penabaker theorizes that the
frequency with which we use certain
pronouns can point to how we're feeling
who we identify with and even might
indicate whether or not we're telling
the truth he also found an interesting
pronoun power Dynamic people in
positions of authority tend to use we in
you at higher rates than their
subordinates if you're emailing your
boss you probably use more eyes than
they do I took a look at my emails and
checks out and now you're going to be
thinking about that next time you write
an email pronouns deserve more credit
than they get our brains tend to ignore
them in favor of the juicier nouns and
verbs but there's a lot going on under
the surface pronouns say a lot about you
both loud and proud when you state your
personal pronouns and also
subconsciously in the way you think and
speak and write we use pronouns every
day in almost every sentence and it'll
be in incredibly awkward to communicate
without them in fact every sentence I've
said has a pronoun in it except one good
luck finding it before you go could a
blind gamer beat you in Mortal Kombat
have you ever heard of a gay rodeo and
why are these guys putting underwear on
goats subcultured a brand new
documentary series from PBS answers
those questions and so many more
exploring lesser known communities and
folks that have had a major impact on
the mainstream check it out over on PBS
voices Link in our description and let
them know that other words sent you
foreign
[Music]